Mr Cena keep confident you'll be prime
minister by this evening he needn't have
looked so nervous out of his front door
this morning not knowing whether he'd be
heading for number 10. by mid-afternoon
it was confirmed all smiles this lot
waiting for their new leader which is
Sonic's supporters so relieved
but a reception to mask the true mood
can you unite the party
divided party a daunting task ahead
and this a prime minister that will need
to rise to the challenge
it is the greatest privilege of my life
to be able to serve the party I love and
give back to the country I owe so much
to
the United Kingdom is a great country
but there is no doubt we Face a profound
economic challenge
we now need stability and unity and I
will make it my utmost priority to bring
our party and our country together
because that is the only way we will
overcome the challenges we face and
build a better more prosperous future
for our children and our grandchildren
I pledge
that I will serve you with integrity and
humility
and I will work day in day out to
deliver for the British people
just after two o'clock came the
announcement that there was another Tory
leader in the space of just eight weeks
banging him back bench leader sir Graham
Brady as the other Contender left the
race Rishi sunak is therefore elected as
leader of the conservative party
just minutes before Penny mordant issued
a statement admitting defeat but calling
for Unity saying I am proud of the
campaign we ran and grateful to all
those across all sides of our party who
gave me their backing we all owe it to
the country to each other and to Rishi
to unite and work together for the good
of the nation there is much work to be
done
this MP had backed Miss mordant but
changed his mind this morning calling on
her to fall behind Rishi sanak I canvas
my Association this morning my executive
and my counselors they were
overwhelmingly the message was it's umps
you've got to come together back
somebody unite behind them and bring the
stability we need don't give us a
contest in the end not a contest but a
coronation Mr sunak with the backing of
over half of the Parliamentary party his
support is not hard to find delighted
Cocker hoop I think this is very good
news for the country I think Rishi sunak
will bring stability he's a very high
quality individual with a great amount
of Integrity we now have a prime
minister who's going to govern in the
interest of the whole country I think
he'll choose the best talents of the
conservative party to make sure we do
that and it will be competent sensible
government but for all his supporters
spin the opposition not convinced
calling for a general election they
can't just keep Doling out Prime
Ministers every month because they're in
total chaos and they've lost control of
the market and haven't got any ideas of
how they're going to tackle the cost of
living that people are facing Tory MPS
have seen the polling they've lived the
chaos they want to end the Mayhem and
Rishi sunak can take comfort that senior
figures from all wings of the party came
out to back him but that public support
is far from Universal privately Penny
Morden I'm told by her team was in touch
and distance of getting the 100 MPS
needed to force him into a runoff she
wanted to fight him the question is do
others too
for now Tory MPS embracing their new
leader he'll be hoping to get the
honeymoon period that Liz trust did not
but his intree isn't getting any easier
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster